في هذا الفصل رح نستكشف
كيف تتعاون الحواسيب الكمية والكلاسيكية
لحل واحدة من أهم التحديات
في العلوم: تقدير طاقة الجزيئات والمواد بدقة
ونقدر نحقق هذا
باستخدام quantum circuit
لتوليد عينات من الحالات
اللي رح نعالجها لاحقاً
ونُقطّر منها مصفوفة أصغر باستخدام خوارزميات التقطير
في هذه العائلة من الخوارزميات
مثل SQD وSKG، وفي كورس كامل على
منصة IBM Quantum مخصص
لها وللطرق المرتبطة بها
لأغراضنا في هذا الدرس رح
نختصر الشرح
سواء كنت تستخدم SQD أو SKG
هدفك هو إيجاد eigenvectors
وقيم eigenvalues لمصفوفة هاملتونية
هاي المصفوفة ممكن تصف طاقة نظام فيزيائي
أو كيميائي، لكن نفس الإطار
يقدر يعالج أنواع كثيرة من المسائل
مثل مسائل اللوجستيات
أحياناً هاي المصفوفات تكون ضخمة جداً
فتصغير أبعادها
مع الحفاظ على الخصائص المهمة
للحالة الأساسية
ممكن يكون ذا قيمة كبيرة، وهذا هو هدف SQD
بنستخدم الحاسوب الكمي لتوليد فضاء جزئي مفيد
يحتوي على الحالة الأساسية
ثم نقدر نسقط مصفوفة هاملتونياننا
على هذا الفضاء الجزئي، وهذا يتركنا
بمصفوفة أصغر ستكون
أسهل بكثير للتحليل
باستخدام الحوسبة الكلاسيكية عالية الأداء، وهذا نعمله
بتحضير حالة كمية تجريبية
يُطلق عليها عادةً ansatz
وإجراء قياسات لأخذ عينات من هذا الـansatz
في الأساس الحسابي، وهذا يعطينا
فضاءً جزئياً مُعيَّناً في الأساس الحسابي
لكن اللي نريد فعلاً إيجاده
هو الحالة الأساسية الحقيقية
ماذا لو كان الفضاء الجزئي المُعيَّن ما احتوى
على كل المكونات الضرورية؟
لو اخترنا ansatz أفضل
ممكن نحصل على تقدير أفضل للحالة الأساسية
وهذا يوصلنا لخوارزميات مبنية على العينات
للتقطير الكمي، أو SKDY، وفي SKDY
نبدأ بـansatz
زي من قبل، لكن بعدين نطبق بعض quantum gates اللي تقرّب
التطور الزمني لنظام فيزيائي
يمكن إثبات أنه ببعض الافتراضات
هذا يؤدي لضمانات على مقدار التداخل بين الـansatz المتطور زمنياً
والحالة الأساسية الحقيقية
كلتا هاتين الخوارزميتين تبدآن بمصفوفة هاملتونية ضخمة
وتعملان بشكل مختلف نوعاً ما
لكن في كلتيهما الجزء الكمي من الخوارزمية ينتج
فضاءً جزئياً يسمح لنا بتصغير مصفوفتنا
بما نأمل أن يحافظ على الخصائص الجوهرية للحالة الأساسية
فأين تدخل الحوسبة الكلاسيكية عالية الأداء؟
في حالة أكبر المصفوفات الهاملتونية
وللحصول على أدق التقديرات للحالة الأساسية
حتى هاي المصفوفات المُسقَطة ممكن تكون كبيرة جداً
لذلك الاستفادة من قدرات الحواسيب الكلاسيكية الأقوى
تقدر تساعدنا ليس فقط
على الحصول على نتائج أفضل
بل أيضاً بالسماح لنا بمعالجة مسائل أكبر
لنجمع كل هذا معاً
نقدر نمثل الخوارزميات المبنية على العينات
كمزيج من نماذج برمجية مختلفة
على مجموعة من الموارد الهجينة
مثلاً، نقدر نمثل خوارزميتنا
كتدفق مهام، حيث سيكون عندنا مهمة
لتحضير quantum circuit تتداخل
مع حالتنا المستهدفة، تليها مهمة
للـtranspiler اللي يحتاج فقط موارد كلاسيكية
ثم تُنفَّذ، والمهمة التالية ستكون
اللي تستخدم primitives لتنفيذ quantum circuit
اللي بالطبع تحتاج موارد كمية
وبعدين سيكون عندنا مهمة معالجة لاحقة قد تكون بحد ذاتها
خوارزمية تقطير متوازية
تشتغل على عدة عقد
بالإضافة لذلك ممكن نريد تشغيل
إحدى هاي الخوارزميات عدة مرات
بينما نغيّر الـansatz
أو نشغّلها بشكل متوازٍ تماماً
بمجموعات مختلفة
الآن لنجمع كل شيء مع SKDY
في الكود، هنا كل ملفات المهام
وهنا كل ملفات التقديم
في مهمة الـmapping نحضّر الـcircuits.
في خطوة الـoptimisation نشغّل الـcircuit بأفضل طريقة.
في مهمة الـexecution نأخذ عينات من الحالات
المحضّرة بواسطة
الـISA circuit الخاص بنا.
اللي نحصل عليه من الخطوة السابقة
ونجري المعالجة اللاحقة.
الآن صرنا جاهزين لتقديم
تدفق العمل الخاص بنا.
كما تشوف، كل شيء مكتوب بالتسلسل
مع التبعيات، خلينا ننتظر
النتائج ونتحقق من ملفات الإخراج.
هنا الملف المفتوح لخطوة الـoptimisation
حيث عندنا الـISA circuit.
والآن لنتحقق أخيراً من نهاية الـ
iteration.
من الجدول الزمني.
وهذا كل شيء للعرض السريع لتدفق عمل SKDY
كل الكود سيكون متاحاً في قسم النص
أو في الوصف أدناه
وهذا كل شيء، لقد مررنا الآن على بعض
المفاهيم والأمثلة اللي ممكن تساعدك على البدء في
إدارة البرامج الهجينة المعقدة، وبالطبع
هذا مجرد غيض من فيض مما يمكنك فعله
بالجمع بين الموارد الكمية
والكلاسيكية، لاستكشاف المزيد
تفقّد الـtutorials والتوثيق
على منصة IBM Quantum
وتأكد من الاطلاع على الموارد المشاركة في قسم النص
أو الوصف لمزيد من المعلومات
والبرامج، شكراً على المشاهدة.
نعم، هذا كل شيء.